TWENTY THREE FIFTY ONE HAS BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR
.
BUSINESS.
YEAH.
OKAY
EVEN THOUGH HE'S.
SINCE ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL IS
HERE WITH US WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND GET STARTED AS A SUB
COMMITTEE LIVING TO FILE I
THREE AB TWO.
THE OTHER THREE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE
OH THREE.
THIS IS A BILL THAT SEEKS TO
GENERATE NEW REVENUE FOR
PROGRAMS LIKE PRESCHOOL AND
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS IN OUR
STATE.
IT RECOGNIZES THAT THERE IS A
NEXUS
WITH THE HIGH RATE OF
INCARCERATION IN OUR STATE IN
PARTICULAR. IT TAKES A LOOK AT
THE PRACTICE OF USING PRIVATE
PRISONS IN OUR STATE.
IN THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SPENDS ON
INCARCERATION SERVICES FOR
COMPANIES THAT ARE FOR PROFIT.
THIS BILL UP PLACES A TEN
PERCENT TAX
ALL FOR PRIVATE ON PRIVATE FOR
PROFIT PRISON COMPANIES THAT
CONTRACT WITH THE STATE. AND
PROFIT OFF OF MASS
INCARCERATION.
A MASS INCARCERATION IS BIG
BUSINESS FOR PRIVATE PRISONS
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA SPENDS HUGE
AMOUNTS TO INCARCERATE PRISONERS
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
THE ACT OF CONTRACTS FOR FOR
POOR PROPER COMPANIES TOTALED
FOUR POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
IN COMPARISON THE STATE SPENDS
RELATIVELY LITTLE ON EARLY
EDUCATION AND AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS THAT WE KNOW WILL
PREVENT INCARCERATION IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
THIS BILL SUPPORTS PROACTIVE
INCARCERATION PREVENTION BY
RAISING APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
FIVE MILLION NEW DOLLARS IN
ANNUAL REVENUE FOR PRESCHOOL AND
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
ATTEMPTS AT REDUCING OUR PRISON
POPULATION TYPICALLY FOCUS ON
RECIDIVISM OR SENTENCING
REDUCTION AND SORT OF ALSO
ADDRESSING THE ROOT OF THE
SYSTEMIC PRISON PIPELINE. THIS
BILL CHANGES THAT TREND
PROVIDING CRUCIAL FUNDING FOR
PROGRAMS THAT REDUCE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF AN INDIVIDUAL
COMING INTO CONTACT WITH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL ADDRESSES
CRITICAL FUNDING ISSUES RELATED
TO EARLY EDUCATION BY PROVIDING
A REVENUE STREAM FOR EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION THAT IS
INSULATED FROM THE ANNUAL BUDGET
VOLATILITY THAT WE EXPERIENCE.
AB TWENTY THREE OH THREE
INCLUDES A NUMBER PROTECTIVE
MEASURES THAT WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT THE COST OF THE TAX IS NOT
PASSED. ON TO THE STATE NOW THAT
LANGUAGE AND HAS BEEN INCLUDED
IS SUCH AS THE FOLLOWING.
REQUIRING CONTRACTING COMPANIES
TO CERTIFY UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY THAT THE COST IS NOT
BEING PASSED ALONG TO THE STATE.
OUR CALLS FOR OVERSIGHT AND
POTENTIAL AUDIT BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
THE INSTITUTION OF CIVIL FINES
FOR COMPANIES FOUND BE VIOLATORS
FINDS AS WELL THAT ARE DEPOSITED
INTO THE FUND FURTHER
INCREASING.
THE AMOUNT OF AVAILABLE MONEY
FOR INCARCERATION PREVENTION
PRIVATE PRISONS.
COMPANIES HAVE BEEN REAPING
LARGE PROFITS EVEN AS A FACE
ACCUSATIONS OF.
INMATE MISTREATMENT AND PRISMS
MANAGEMENT THERE'S AN ONGOING
LAWSUIT OVER IN MAKE CONDITIONS
WITH LAWYERS FOR THE ACLU AND
THE SOUTHERN POPULAR CENTER.
ALLEGING THAT MEDICAL CARE IS
SUBSTANDARD AND INMATES ARE
OFTEN BEING DENIED FOOD FURTHER
LATE LAST YEAR THESE COMPANIES
WERE FOUND TO PARTNER WITH
RETAILERS TO EXTORT SHOPLIFTERS.
INTO TAKING A RE EDUCATION
COURSE COSTING HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS OR FACE JAIL TIME. THIS
BILL MAKES PRIVATE PRISON
MANAGEMENT LESS PROFITABLE WHILE
GENERATING FUNDS FOR EARLY
EDUCATION A WITH ME TODAY THAT
TESTIFYING AT EMPHASIS ON THIS
BILL. IS AIRING GABLE
REPRESENTING FIRST FIVE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR BIBLE.
HI AARON GABLE ABOUT FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA THE STATE COMMISSION
AS WELL AS A BOARD MEMBER FOR
THE PARTNERSHIP FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH. AND I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND TO THAT THE
COMMITTEE FOR NOT ONLY THINKING
ABOUT HOW TO FIND MORE REVENUES
FOR THE CRUCIAL LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES OF EARLY LEARNING AN
EXPANDED LEARNING. BUT ALSO FOR
THIS PRIORITY OF FINDING THE
NEXUS BETWEEN THE OPPORTUNITY
GAP IN THE FIRST YEARS OF LIFE
AND OUR INCARCERATION RATE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE BRAIN SCIENCE AND THE
CONCLUSIVE NATIONAL RESEARCH
OUTLINES WHY AND HOW THE
OPPORTUNITY GAP.
BECOMES OUR ACHIEVEMENT GAP OR
TAKE A TWELVE SCHOOLS REGION IS
EXPANDED BY LACK OF OPPORTUNITY
INTO A HIGH SCHOOL DROPOUT
RATES.
WHICH ULTIMATELY LEADS TO OUR
INCREDIBLE INCARCERATION RATES.
CALIFORNIA MUST BEGIN WITH
STRATEGIC INVESTMENTS PROVEN BY
RESEARCH TO REDUCE THESE
INCARCERATION RATES BY GOING
UPSTREAM.
WE NEED TO INVEST IN HIGH
QUALITY CHILDCARE AND PRESCHOOL
IN THE FIRST FIVE YEARS OF LIFE
WHEN NINETY PERCENT OF THE BRAIN
DEVELOPMENTS OCCURRING. IN THE
ARCHITECTURE FOR ENTIRE TYRE
CHILD'S FUTURE IS AT STAKE.
THAT OPPORTUNITY GAP HERE IN
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY MEANS THAT
ONLY FOURTEEN PERCENT OF OUR
BABIES HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY CHILDCARE WHEN EIGHTY
PERCENT OF THE BRAIN
DEVELOPMENTS OCCURRING. ONLY
THIRTY EIGHT PERCENT ARE
ELIGIBLE THREE YEAR OLDS HAVE
ACCESS TO PRESCHOOL.
I WE ALSO NEED TO BE LOOKING AT
HOW TO INVEST IN CONTINUE TO
EXPAND INVESTMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORIC EXPANDED
LEARNING PROGRAMS ADDRESSING THE
SUMMER LEARNING LOSS.
SUMMERLEARNING GAPS AND THE
LACK OF ACCESS TO AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS WHICH GIVE CHILDREN A
BOTH SAFE AND LEARNING PLACE TO
BE.
WE SPEND CURRENTLY MORE ON FOR
PROFIT PRISONS THAN WE DO ON ALL
OF EARLY LEARNING IN CALIFORNIA
AND THAT'S A TREND THAT NEEDS TO
STOP. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER BAKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION PLEASED TO BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION TO REALLY HOPE TO
CLOSE THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE AS WAS NOTED EARLIER
OUR EARLIER IT'S LEARNERS.
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY GAP THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE START
AT THE BEGINNING OF THEIR
EDUCATIONAL CAREER SAID THAT
THEY HAVE OPPORTUNITIES TO
SUCCEED. SO MANY OF OUR CHILDREN
HAVE NOT HAD THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
WE BELIEVE THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE WOULD HELP TO PROVIDE
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT THEY SO
DEARLY ME.
MANAGER MEMBERS BRIAN HOW WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON AYE MONICA'S AYE
ME WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION AND MARIN SUPPORT.
RYAN BLAKELY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
LET'S GET A.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON DAVID WOLF PARA JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION THAT
OPPOSED AB TWENTY THREE A THREE
TODAY.
MET MEMBERS WERE OBVIOUSLY IN
FAVOR OF EARLY LEARNING PROGRAMS
AND PROTECTING AGAINST STAFF
FUTURE RECIDIVISM RATES AND ALL
THOSE THINGS BUT. IMPOSING A TAX
SOME PRIVATE PRISONS BACK
CONTRACT OUT WITH VENDORS IS.
INAPPROPRIATE AND POTENTIALLY
VERY DAMAGING FOR SMALL
BUSINESS.
.
ACCORDING TO THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND MR THURMAN
NOTED THIS IT DOES COST A LOT TO
HAS AN INMATE IN CALIFORNIA
PRISON SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO HOUSE AN INMATE FOR
ONE YEAR WHICH IS MORE THAN THE
TUITION RIGHT. AT HARVARD
UNIVERSITY.
.
IT SEEMS LIKE THAT ALONE SHOULD
BE SUFFICIENT RATIONALE TO
CONTINUE CONTRACTING OUT MORE
SERVICES INSTEAD OF STIFLING
ECONOMIC GROWTH BY TAXING IT.
AND TAXING ARTS YOU KNOW AGAIN
THE MAJORITY OF THESE VENDORS
ARE SMALL BUSINESSES.
YOU KNOW AND AGAIN MR THURMAN
MENTIONED THAT.
THE VENDOR WOULD HAVE TO
CERTIFY UNDER PENALTY OF PERJURY
THAT ANY COSTS AS A RESULT OF
ATTACKS AND NOT BE PASSED ON TO
THE STATE. HOW YOU GONNA PROVE
US?
NOW WE THE QUESTION I HAVE IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO PROVE AND IT'S
GOING TO SERVE AS YET ANOTHER
DISINCENTIVE FOR THESE VENDORS
TO CONTRACT OUT SO FOR THOSE
REASONS ASPIRIN OVER.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MR BARREL INTO A CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
WE SIMPLY BELIEVE THAT
COMPANIES THAT ARE PROFITING OFF
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
A RESPONSIBILITY. TO HELP TO
PREVENT FURTHER INCARCERATION.
WE THINK THAT THIS BILLS
CREATIVE ITS APPROACH TO PREVENT
COSTS AND BEING PASSED ON TO THE
STATE. AND RECOGNIZING THAT
THERE IS A NEXUS BETWEEN.
PROGRAMS LIKE PRESCHOOL WHICH
PREVENT.
YOUNG PEOPLE FROM ENTERING A CAN
OF JUSTICE SYSTEM IN THE FIRST
PLACE ARE THIS CREATES A NEW
REVENUE SOURCE TO HELP GET
THEIR.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE AYE
VOTE OF THIS COMMITTEE.
I ONCE WE HAVE A QUORUM WE WILL.
THANK YOU.
WE NEED.
WHAT WERE WE NEED ONE MORE?
I THINK YOU AND THIS THIS WILL
RECORD THIS SO THE ACTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
RECOMMENDATION.
FROM THE CHAIR.
BROUGH ONLY HAVE A QUORUM THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
WELL YOU HAVE ANOTHER WELL I
THINK WASTE OF SINGER.
OKAY.
WE'RE GONNA FILE ITEM SIX AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY.
MR VERY WHAT DO I SORRY TO BE
SIT NARAL FACT.
I WOULD DO THAT WAS SECOND.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY.
THE BILL HAS A DIFFERENT A
SIMILAR THING. ARE IT LOOKS THAT
COMPANIES THAT PROFIT OFF OF
PRISON RELATED SERVICES BUT
WHEREAS THE LAST BILL WAS FOCUS
EXCLUSIVELY ON PRIVATE PRISON
COMPANIES. THIS BILL LOOKS AT
ANY COMPANY THAT. UP HAS A
PROFIT NOT RELATED.
COMPONENT FOR PRISON RELATED
SERVICES
NOW THIS BILL PROVIDES RESOURCES
FOR PRESCHOOL AND AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS.
UNLIKE AB TWENTY THREE OH THREE
AT IT PLACES A PROGRESSIVE BE
ALL FOR PROFIT COMPANIES OTHER
THAN PRIVATE PRISON AND HEALTH
CONTRACTORS THAT CONTRACT WITH
THE STATE. TO PROVIDE GOODS AND
SERVICES
THE FEE WOULD GENERATE ABOUT A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TRADING A CONTINUOUS
SOURCE OF FUNDING. FOR PRESCHOOL
AND AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS THAT
IS NOT DEPENDENT ON ANNUAL
BUDGET APPROPRIATION.
I WE'RE COMMITTED TO ENSURING
THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT HARM
CALIFORNIA INMATES AND TO THAT
END WE RECOGNIZE A CERTAIN
CONTRACTS. SPECIFICALLY THOSE
INVOLVING HEALTH CARE MUST BE
TREATED DIFFERENTLY THAT IS WHY
THIS BILL EXEMPTS HEALTH
CONTRACTS FROM THIS FEAT THIS
BILL ALSO EXAM CONTRACTS OF ONE
MILLION DOLLARS OR LESS. TO
ENSURE THAT SMALL BUSINESS
CONTRACTORS ARE NOT UNDULY
IMPACT IT. AND ADDITIONALLY THE
BILL WILL INCREASE TRANSPARENCY
BY CREATING A PUBLICLY
ACCESSIBLE DATABASE WERE
CONTRACTORS CONTRACT VALUES
TANTRIC SUMMARIES. AND ANNUAL
CONTRACT PAYOUTS WILL BE LISTED
FINALLY AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
INCLUDE THE SAME PROTECTION
MEASURES CONTAINED. IN THE
PREVIOUS BILL THAT WILL HELP TO
ENSURE THAT THE COST OF THE TAX
IS NOT PASSED ON TO THE STATE.
THE BILL ONLY AFFECT THOSE WHO
PROFIT FINANCIALLY FROM
INDIVIDUALS INCARCERATION AND
REMIT THOSE FUNDS TO PROGRAMS
THAT WILL REDUCE INCARCERATION.
AND PROVIDE FOR A BETTER FUTURE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS AYE WITH ME
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
IS AND GABLE A FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA JENNIFER BAKER OF
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
RESPECT ESPERANDO.
AARON A CABLE ABOUT THE FOR SIDE
CALIFORNIA AGAIN IN THE
PARTNERSHIP FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH I WANNA. DEFERRED THE
COMMENTS I MADE EARLIER
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING A STATE
INCARCERATION PREVENTION FUND TO
LOOK AT THIS NEXUS A RIGHT NOW
IF YOU THINK ABOUT A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IS
BEING. A SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY
IN THE FACE OF WHAT WE SEE IN
TERMS OF A LACK OF ACCESS AND
EARLY LEARNING EVERY JUST GIVE
YOU THE CONTEXT. THAT HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS WITH
SERVE APPROXIMATELY TWELVE
THOUSAND MORE CHILDREN IN
PRESCHOOL SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA
THAN WE CURRENTLY DO. BY BY
CONTEXT WE ONLY CURLY SERVE
ABOUT THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
CHILDREN AGES ZERO TO TWO IN OUR
HIGH QUALITY EARLY LEARNING
PROGRAMS OF THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE POTENTIAL
THANK YOU.
JENNIFER BAKER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO A CO MY
PREVIOUS COMMENTS BUT ALSO NOTE
THAT IT.
ONE OF OUR GUYS STATE COUNCIL
MEETINGS THAT WE HAD.
OR LAST YEAR WHERE IS THIS.
IMPORTER LEE MEETINGS WHERE ARE
OUR MEMBERS COME FROM ACROSS THE
STATE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT LEGISLATION.
OUR MEMBERS WERE PARTICULARLY
INTENSE OVER THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELINE AND WE'RE TRYING
TO FIND CREATIVE WAYS TO BE ABLE
TO SAY HOW DO WE ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE SYSTEMICALLY. SO WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
THURMAN AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS MATTER IN
SUPPORT.
MANAGER MEMBER BRIAN HA.
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WE APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
SUBMITTING AS A LOT OF SUPPORT
WILL BE JUST TOOK POSITION ON
THE BELGRADE STRONG SUPPORT.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HELLO AGAIN.
MONICA SEMI WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MARTY FISHER ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE.
WERE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
WE AGREE THAT REDUCING
INCARCERATION IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICY AREA BUT
WE DISAGREE WITH THE PROPOSED
REVENUE SOURCE. A SET FORTH IN
THIS BILL. WE'VE IDENTIFIED IT
AS A JOB KILLER.
THE BILL UNFAIRLY TARGETS ONE
CATEGORY OF TAXPAYERS TO FUND A
BENEFIT FOR ALL OF THE STATE BY
IMPOSING A TAX OF UP TO TEN
PERCENT ON THE CONTRACT PRICE.
ON CONTRACTORS FOR THE PRIVILEGE
OF DOING BUSINESS WITH THIS
AUDIT DEPARTMENT.
AND REQUIRES THE CONTRACTOR TO
ABSORB THE COST WHILE
MAINTAINING A PRICE OF THE
LOWEST RESPONSIBLE BIDDER WE
DON'T THINK THIS IS THIS IS EVEN
POSSIBLE. CONTRACTORS AND
VENDORS ARE PLEASED TO DO
BUSINESS WITH THE STATE I CAN
ATTRIBUTE A PORTION OF THEIR
SUCCESS TO THAT RELATIONSHIP. AN
ADDED TAX ON TOP OF AN ALREADY
RESOURCE INTENSIVE CONTRACTING
PROCESS FOR BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA COULD JEOPARDIZE THE
VIABILITY OF CONTRACTING WITH US
DEPARTMENT. OF COST CAN'T BE
CALCULATED INTO THE BIG
EQUATION.
AN UNDULY BURDENSOME TAX
STRUCTURE BUILT IN THE
CONTRACTING WILL ULTIMATELY
RESULT IN A LOSS TO THE STATE.
OF QUALIFIED AND COMPETITIVE
BIDDERS AS WELL AS A LOSS OF
BUSINESS THE VENDORS THAT THE
STATE HAS COME TO RELY ON ITS
QUALITY. AND DEPENDABLE WE'VE
CONSISTENTLY STATED THAT ANY TAX
INCREASE SHOULD BE BROAD BASED
AND SHARED BY ALL SO THAT THE
FINANCIAL IMPACT IS MITIGATED
THESE AND OTHER REASONS FOR
POST.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
SHOW SHAUN LEWIS OF THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS REPRESENTING OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS AN ASCETIC CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN OPPOSITION FOR THE
REASONS ALREADY STATED WOULD
LIKE TO JUST ADD THREE QUICK
POINTS.
FIRST WE AGREE THAT THIS BILL I
THINK HIS GOOD INTENTIONS BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WITH BAD PUBLIC
POLICY AYE WE ALSO FULLY SUPPORT
THE INTENT IN NEED.
TO SUPPORT AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS MORE BROADLY REDUCE
RECIDIVISM IN THE STATE BUT WE
THINK THIS BILL GOES ABOUT IT
THE WRONG WAY.
ACTUALLY VIOLATES OUR FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY TAXPAYERS OUGHT
TO SEEK THE MOST COMPETITIVE LOW
COST BIDS OF FOR STATE CONTRACTS
BY IMPOSING THIS HEAVY. TEN
PERCENT TAX.
SECOND OF ALL SPECIFIC TO SMALL
BUSINESSES SEEKING TO CONTRACT
WITH THE STATE AYE WE THINK THIS
BILL UNDERMINES EXISTING.
POLICY GOAL OF AWARDING AT
LEAST TWENTY FIVE PERCENT OF ALL
STATE DOLLARS OUT OF STATE
CONTRACT DOLLARS TO CERTIFIED
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT'S EXISTING
POLICY WE THINK TO BE
UNDERMINED.
I'M BY RAISING THE COST OF ALL
THESE CONTRACTS I'M WITHOUT THE
ABILITY TO BUILD THIS TAX IN THE
COST STRUCTURE ITSELF IT REALLY
SPECIFICALLY PUT SMALL
BUSINESSES AT A SEVERE
DISADVANTAGE.
WHEN IT COMES TO COMPETITIVE
BIDDING SINCE THEY ALREADY BEEN
ON SUCH TIGHT MARGINS AND
FINALLY WE JUST MORE BROADLY
DISAGREE I THINK WHAT THE
GENERAL. CHARACTERIZATION IS OF
THESE CONTRACTS AS A PRIVILEGE
OR PROFITEERING OUR TO THOSE
CONTRACTING WITH THE STATE MOST
STATE AGENCIES FAR BEYOND CDC
ARE.
LEGITIMATELY NEED CERTAIN GOODS
AND SERVICES.
CONTRACTED OUT THAT THEY ARE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THEMSELVES.
OR EVEN IF THEY ARE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THESE CONTRACTS ARE
SERVICES OTHER MAYBE WAYS TO CUT
COSTS AND SAVE TAXPAYER DOLLARS
BY CONTRACTING ESPECIALLY WITH A
SMALL BUSINESS WE THINK. THAT
THAT IT'S JUST BAD POLICY.
WITHIN THIS BILL WHEN IT COMES
TO THE NEGATIVE CHARACTERIZATION
AYE WE BELIEVE THESE CONTRACTS
ARE ACTUALLY A WIN WIN FOR
TAXPAYERS AND PRIVATE ENTERPRISE
WHICH WE DO MORE TO ENCOURAGE IS
PRACTICE. NOT PENALIZE IT WITH
THIS TEN PERCENT TAX WE ASK YOU
KNOW VOTE.
ANY MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS DAVID
WOLFE OUR JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION FOR REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED IN MY PRIOR
TESTIMONY ASPIRIN ABOUT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
DOCTOR QUIRK OF.
SO WE ALREADY HAVE A BILL OF
BOXES BILL FROM A YEAR TO GO
WHICH SAYS WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
CONTRACTING WITH PRISON THAT
PRIVATE PRISONS.
WHY DID YOU DECIDE TO BRING THIS
BILL UP NOW?
THANKS FOR THE QUESTION IS ARE
NOT REQUIRED AND I WILL CLARIFY
THAT THIS BILL IS NOT THE ONE
ABOUT PRIVATE PRISONS LE A BLIND
NO BUT I WAS IN HERE FOR THE
PRIVATE DOZEN ONE BUT THIS DEALS
WITH PEOPLE. TELLING TO PRIVATE
PRISONS.
SO WE'RE NOT EXPECTING TO HAVE
ANY.
SO WHY BRING THE BILL UP.
WELL ON AB TWENTY THREE OH THREE
WHICH DEALS EXCLUSIVELY A
PRIVATE PRISONS WE SIMPLY ARE
SAYING IF THE STATE IS GOING TO
CONTRACT WITH PRIVATE PRISONS.
THAT THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
MUCH NEEDED REVENUE TO SUPPORT
PREVENTION PROGRAMS AND UNTIL
THERE ARENO PRIVATE PRISONS WE
BELIEVE THAT THEY SHOULD BE IN
FACT POLICY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
OKAY BUT THEN.
AYE KNOW THAT YOU HAVE SAID THAT
THE PRISONS HAVE TO PAY.
ARM.
ONCE THERE'S A CONTRACT RENEWAL.
I'M SURE THE PRICE OF THAT WILL
GO UP.
BECAUSE THEY SEE THEIR EXPENSES
GOING OUT BOTH FOR THE PEOPLE
YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT IN THIS
SPELL THE ACTOR. PEOPLE THEY
CONTRACT WITH.
YOU KNOW WINDOWS CONTRACTS WILL
BE RENEWED IN THERE FOR THE
PRICES WILL GO UP.
YOU KNOW THEY ARE MULTI YEAR
CONTRACTS.
BY MOST ESTIMATES TWENTY
NINETEEN IS WHEN THERE WOULD BE
NEW CONTRACT CONVERSATIONS. IS
CERTAINLY WILL BE INCUMBENT ON
OUR STATE AGENCIES TO MONITOR
THEIR ANY ON PRICING CHANGES IN
A PRIOR TO THOSE DATES.
ON IN IF THERE WAS SOME
SIGNIFICANT BOOST IN COSTS AT
THE TIME OF A NEW CONTRACT IT
WILL BE UP TO THE STATE TO
DETERMINE IF THAT WAS A
REASONABLE INCREASE. OFFER THE
SERVICES BEING PROVIDED.
WELL I MEAN THEY CAN SAY WE GOT
TO PAY TEN PERCENT MORE AND PLUS
THE CONTRA BUTTON THAT BE
CONSIDERED. A REASONABLE.
COST BY THE STATE I DON'T KNOW
I'VE.
JUST ASKING.
BUT I THINK WE'RE SAYING THAT
THE STATE NEEDS TO MAKE A
STATEMENT OF ITS VALUES AND THAT
IF THE STATE IS SPENDING FOUR
AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS IN.
ON A SERVICE THAT LARGELY I HAS
A NEGATIVE OUTCOME ON CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS.
INCLUDING WHAT THE TAXPAYERS
PAY WHY SHOULD THE TAXPAYERS
ALSO EXPERIENCE SOME BENEFIT BY
HAVING REVENUE THAT IS CREATED
TO HELP PREVENT. AND ULTIMATELY.
CHRIS THE NOT ACROSS ORATION
THAT CALIFORNIANS PAY FOR OUR
STATE WHAT THE CONCERN THERE IS
JUST THAT IT'S GOING TO COST THE
STATE MONEY.
COMING FROM ONE PRODUCT POCKET
THEN YOU'RE PUTTING ANOTHER.
.
BECAUSE I GET NOW I DON'T THINK
A PRISONS GONNA STAY OPEN IF
IT'S LOSING MONEY.
AND UNDER YOUR BILL THAT WOULD
BE LOSING MONEY IF IT HAD TO PAY
ALL THESE FEES.
SO THAT THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT.
WELL THESE COMPANIES OPERATE IN
MULTIPLE STATES AND
JURISDICTIONS IN THEY ARE HIGHLY
PROFITABLE AND SO IT'S
QUESTIONABLE THAT THEY'RE LOSING
MONEY EVEN IN THE FACE. OF
PAYING AN ADDITIONAL FEE THE FUN
CERTAIN SERVICES THAT HAVE A
NEXUS TO WHAT THEY DO THESE
COMPANIES REMAIN HIGHLY
PROFITABLE.
AND I BELIEVE.
THE CALIFORNIA WOULD MAKE IN
THE RIGHT STATEMENT BY SAYING.
THERE'S AN EXPECTATION THAT
THESE COMPANIES WILL CONTRIBUTE
TO SOMETHING THAT WILL
ULTIMATELY REDUCE THE LEVEL OF
INCARCERATION OUR STATE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SOME OF OUR VOEPEL.
AS I AM SOME OF THE OTHER
OPPOSITION PEOPLE HAVE SAID THIS
UP I SEE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO. AND IT'S GOOD.
AND IT'S IT'S HONORABLE TRYING
TO GET MORE MONEY. TO CHILDREN.
TO.
HELP AMOUNT AND MAKE SURE THEY.
DON'T END UP GOING DOWN A BAD
PATH GOT IT.
I HAVE THE COUPLE.
ANGLES ON IS AND ONE IS RIGHT
NOW PROP NINETY EIGHT IS FULLY
FUNDED.
AND THE QUE.
THROUGH TWELVE.
MANY OF THE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS
ARE FULLY FUNDED.
AND.
THEY'RE OPERATING ON THEIR
HITTING ON ALL CYLINDERS IT'S
ACTUALLY THE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS
RIGHT NOW ARE DOING VERY WELL.
M. THEY'RE FULLY FUNDED SO
THAT'S
THAT ONE YOU KNOW THE THING IS.
WHAT? DOUBLE WOULD BEEN APPEAR
YEAR MAYBE A LITTLE BIT MORE.
WHAT I'VE BEEN WATCHING IS LAYER
AFTER LAYER AFTER LAYER AFTER
LAYER OF TAXES BEING ADDED ON?
TO EVERYTHING I CAN'T THINK OF
ANY CATEGORY WE DON'T TAX A
LITTLE BIT MORE. AND IT'S ALL
CUMULATIVE.
AND.
THIS PARTICULAR TAX.
IS.
AS WELL MEANT IS IT IS.
WILL.
STIFLE. ANY VENDOR I MADE MY
LIVING FOR MANY YEARS PROVIDING
THE HIGHEST VALUE. FOR THE
LOWEST PRICE POSSIBLE.
AND IF I'M NOT ALLOWED.
TO.
FACTOR IN A TEN PERCENT TAX
BECAUSE.
THE LANGUAGE IS VERY CLEAR.
IF I RAISE MY PRICE TEN PERCENT
TO COVER MY COST OF THE TAX.
THEN I CAN BE PERSECUTED
PROSECUTED EVERY WHICH WAY.
SO.
THAT MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT.
FOR THE PRIVATE SECTOR TO
RESPOND TO THIS
PARTICULAR TAX SO THOSE ARE MY
TWO MAIN POINTS.
.
JUST SO YOU KNOW.
WHAT IT RESPONDS YES THANK YOU
THROUGH THE CHAIR?
?
YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
CONCERNS AND THAT YOU'VE
ARTICULATED.
AT THE TOP AS YOU TALKED ABOUT
PROP NINETY EIGHT HOW EDUCATION
IS FUNDED.
ARE CURRENT. FUNDING FORMULA
SEES US FUNDED IN THE STATE
SOMEWHERE AROUND FORTY SIX IN
THE NATION IN PER PUPIL
SPENDING.
IN CALIFORNIA HAS A VERY.
MUCH LOWER.
AT LEVEL OF ENGAGEMENT AND IN
PRESCHOOL ACTIVITY OF THAT WE
WOULD HOPE FOR AND I BELIEVE
THAT MISS CABLE CAN SPEAK TO
WHERE WE RANK ARE WHERE WE ARE
IN OUR PARTICIPATION RATES BUT
THEY'RE MUCH LOWER. THAN NEEDED
AND HOPE FOR THE STATE.
JUST TO CLARIFY BECAUSE I I
THINK IT'S WONDERFUL AS A MEMBER
TO HEAR THAT YOU THINK ARE
PRESCHOOL FIRMS ARE DOING WELL
BECAUSE THEY DO SERVE WEALTHY
CHILDREN WHO WERE ABLE TO BE IN
THE PROGRAM. WE CURRENTLY ONLY
SERVE SIXTY SEVEN PERCENT OF
ELIGIBLE FOR YOUR ROLES DESPITE
THE STATE'S GOAL TO SERVE ALL
ELIGIBLE FOR YOUR OLDER THAT'S
BASED OFF OF INCOME. AND WORKING
STATUS OF THE PARENTS WE I'M
CURRENTLY ONLY SERVED THIRTY
EIGHT PERCENT OF ELIGIBLE THREE
YEAR OLDS AND A PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM AND SO THAT WE DO HAVE
VERY LOW PARTICIPATION RATES.
NOT BASED OFF OF INTEREST BUT
BASS OFF OF THE FUNDING
AVAILABLE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
STILL I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
MYSELF.
.
FIRST ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE WHERE
WE REVIEWED NOTHING BUT TAX
OVERTAXED OVER TAXES YOU'RE
GOING TO SEAL A LOT OF TAXES
HERE.
I NOTICED THAT EVERYONE IN THE
ROOM WANTS TO SAY THAT THEY WANT
TO REDUCE RECIDIVISM BUT NO
WANTS TO PAY FOR IT.
CLEARLY I REPRESENT A COMMITTEE
WHERE THIS IS AN ISSUE AND HOW
WE AND ONE OF THE BEST WAYS IS
IS THROUGH EARLY EDUCATION I
HAVE A THREE YEAR OLDS. THE FACT
THIRTY EIGHT PERCENT OF THREE
YEAR OLDS ARE ALLOWED ACCESS.
TO TO.
EDUCATION IS INSANE TO ME THAT
SIXTY PERCENT OF WHERE MY
DAUGHTER MOVES TO NEXT WOULD BE
WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR HER. IS
UNACCEPTABLE TO ME I DO HAVE ONE
QUESTION WITH THIS ARE EITHER
BILL MAKE PREP PRISONS NON
PROFITABLE FOR PRIVATE PRISONS.
TEN PERCENT WOULD THAT MAKE IT
EITHER PREP WOULD THAT MAKE IT
NOT PROFITABLE I'D I DO NOT
THINK SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
RATE OF PROFITABILITY FOR. THE
COMPANIES THAT OWN PRIVATE
PRISONS IT IS SIGNIFICANT AND
GROWING AND.
I DO NOT THINK SO.
IT IS NOT FOR ME TO DETERMINE
WHAT THEIR PROFITABILITY IS BUT
I WOULD ONLY ILLUSTRATE THAT THE
PROFITABILITY IS SIGNIFICANT AT
THIS TIME.
THANK YOU AND IN Y OPINION
CAPITALISM IS THE HIGHEST VALUE
FOR THE LOWEST COSTS TENDS TO BE
SO WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE CLOSE.
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I WOULD ONLY
SAY THIS ABOUT SOME OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE FROM
OPPOSITION. ABOUT THIS BILL
DISADVANTAGING SMALL BUSINESS
WE'VE ACTUALLY TAKEN GREAT PAINS
TO PROTECT SMALL BUSINESS BY
EXEMPTING ANY BUSINESS WHOSE.
GROSS RECEIPTS ARE BELOW ONE
MILLION DOLLARS.
WIT WE UNDERSTAND.
THAT THERE ARE ISSUES AROUND
TAXATION.
CALIFORNIA IS A STATE THAT
NEEDS REVENUE. AND CALIFORNIA IS
A STATE THAT HAS SAID NO NEW
PROGRAMS WITHOUT ANY REVENUE.
AND SO WE'VE TAKEN THAT TO HEART
AND WE'RE TRYING OUR BEST TO
STEWART THE PUBLIC RESOURCES AT
OUR CITIZENS PROVIDE US.
AND I THINK THIS PROVIDES THE
MOST IMPACT OF FOR THE VALUE
THAT WE WILL GET FOR STUDENTS
AND YOUNG PEOPLE IN OUR STATE OF
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. FOR AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
AND AB TWENTY THREE OH THREE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
WE HAVE A QUORUM WE WILL VOTE
THIS RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
WELL IN A FILE ITEM FIVE AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY SEVEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS A STUDY CONDUCTED BY THE
U. S. SECRET SERVICE IN THE US
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION SHOW THAT
EIGHTY ONE PERCENT OF SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS. AT LEAST ONE OTHER
PERSON
BESIDES THE SHOOTER HAD
INFORMATION ABOUT THE ATTACK.
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY SEVEN THE
SCHOOL VIOLENCE.
IS EXCUSE ME THE SCHOOL GUN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION ACT WILL PUT
IN PLACE THE PROPER PERSONNEL.
THE PROPER PROCEDURE SO THAT
CRITICAL INFORMATION WILL NOT BE
IGNORED. BUT ACTED UPON.
AB TWENTY FOUR NIGHTS SEVEN
WOULD POSE AN EXERCISE IN SELF
TAX ON ALL FIREARMS AND
AMMUNITION CELLS.
THE REVENUE FROM ATTACKS MADE
AVAILABLE TO. ALL MIDDLE SCHOOL
TO HIGH SCHOOL COUNSELOR AND ALL
HIGH SCHOOL TO HIGH SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICER.
IT'S CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE THE
PROGRAM.
IT BETWEEN FOR NINETY SEVEN WILL
ALSO ALLOW THE PUBLIC JUSTICE TO
FLAG INDIVIDUALS WHO IDENTIFIED
IN THE PLANNING OF A SCHOOL
SHOOTING SLEW ARE NOT PERMITTED
TO PURCHASE ANY FIREARMS.
IT WILL ALSO PLEASE PENALTIES ON
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO MAKE THEIR
OWN NOT REPORTED FIRE ARMS WITH
THE INTENT TO RESELL.
AB TWENTY FOUR NINE SEVEN PLACES
PERSONNEL IN MIDDLE SCHOOLS WERE
THE FIRST SIGNS STUDENTS IN
DISTRESS MANIFEST THEMSELVES IN
PLACES OFFERS A HIGH SCHOOLS TO
ADDRESS INSTANCE OF ACTIVE
SHOOTERS.
I RESPECTFULLY ACCEPT CHAIRS
RECKON AMID AMENDMENTS.
THAT MARCH FIFTH WE ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WHEN IS IT IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS ABOUT.
HERE THEY COME.
GOOD AFTERNOON. CATHY SURE ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA.
.
VERY BRIEFLY WE DO NOT WE TAKE
NO POSITION ON THE PORTION OF
THE BILL THAT PER THAT PROPOSALS
AND USE TAX ON SALES OF FIREARMS
AND AMMUNITION. BUT WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT THE WAY TO SPEND
THAT MONEY IS ON MORE POLICE IN
SCHOOLS.
AND ANEW KIND OF SCHOOL
COUNSELOR FOR MIDDLE SCHOOLS.
FOR MANY STUDENTS UP PRESENCE
OF A SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICER
MAKES SCHOOL FEEL LESS SAFE.
THEY'RE OFF ALL TOO OFTEN USED
TO ASSIST WITH WHAT WHAT SHOULD
BE ROUTINE DISCIPLINARY MATTERS
AND ALL TOO OFTEN THOSE
INTERACTIONS HAVE TURNED INTO A
BOMB EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE
AGAINST STUDENTS.
YOUNG PEOPLE COME TO FEEL THAT
THEY'RE TREATED AS SUSPECTS
RATHER THAN STUDENTS
AND WE SHOULD BE LOOKING FOR
WAYS TO REDUCE THE PRESENCE OF
POLICE IN OUR SCHOOLS RATHER
THAN INCREASE AT.
I IN GENERAL WE THINK THAT THAT
COUNSELORS MORE COUNSELORS IN
SCHOOLS IS A BETTER APPROACH TO
CREATING SAFER SCHOOLS. UP BUT
THE LANGUAGE DESCRIBING THE ROLE
OF THE COUNSELOR IN THIS BILL IS
SOMEWHAT DISTURBING.
RATHER THAN BEING TRADITIONAL
SCHOOL COUNSELORS WHO WHO
PROVIDE HELP ON A RANGE OF
ISSUES THAT ARISE ACADEMIC AND
OTHERWISE FOR STUDENTS.
THESE COUNSELORS ARE DEFINED AS.
HAVING THEIR PRIMARY ROLE IS
DETECTING IN REPORTING THE EARLY
WARNING SIGNS OF THREATS OF
VIOLENCE TO THE SCHOOL OR ITS
PUPILS.
TO US THAT SOUNDS A LOT MORE
LIKE SURVEILLANCE THAN IT DOES.
.
I BREAK TRADITIONAL COUNSELLING.
AND WE ASK FOR AN OF.
JUST TO BE CLEAR LET'S RUN
THROUGH THEM EMMETT SO THAT SO
THAT WE DON'T TALK ABOUT. THE
AUTHOR HAS AGREED TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS AND SEND SOME OF THE
COMMENTS MAY BE ABOUT THE
AMENDMENTS AND HE'S ACCEPTED TO
TAKE LET'S GO THROUGH THEM
REALLY QUICKLY. THE FIRST ONE IS
DELETE SCHOOL COUNSELOR FROM
THIS BILL'S PROVISION I'M
MANDATE REPORTERS DELETE DELETE
SECTION FOUR OF THE BILL WHICH
PROVIDES A NEW EXCEPTION TO THE
CONFIDENTIALITY RULES GOVERNING
SCHOOL COUNSELORS. DELETE
LANGUAGE IN SECTION FIVE STAY IN
THAT SCHOOL COUNSELORS WILL BE
PRIMARILY CHARGED WITH DETECTING
REPORTING THE EARLY WARNING
SIGNS OF VIOLENCE.
PROVIDE THE NEW COUNSELORS
FUNDING SHALL BE USED TO
SUPPLEMENT ARE NOT SUPPLANT
EXISTING FUNDING FOR COUNSELORS
AND TO ADOPT TECHNICAL MOMENTS
NOTED INCOME IN EACH OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
SO TO BE CLEAR THERE HAS BEEN
AND I'VE SPENT TWO NIGHTS
CONCERNS NOT HAVING REVIEWED.
I WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
CONTINUE. UPMANTRA MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CRADLE IS ABOUT
FOR THE FIVE POLICY COALITION
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FEDERAL FIREARMS LICENSEES.
I'M.
ON ON MANY LEVELS THIS BILL IS
TROUBLING FIRST RELATING TO JUST
THE ISSUES OF THE THE INCREASED
POTENTIAL CRIMINAL LIABILITIES.
TO MANDATE A REPORTERS OF THE
THE DEFINITIONS OF WHAT IS A
THREAT ARE SO HIGHLY SUBJECTIVE
I IN THIS PARTICULAR MEASURE AND
IT WOULD BE WOULD OPEN UP THOSE
MANDATED REPORTERS TO.
POTENTIAL JAIL TIME AS WELL AS
FINES. OF. BUT ONCE AGAIN DID
THOSE ARE MORE RELATING TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUES IN REGARDS
TO A TAXATION ISSUE AND AND
SOMETHING WAS BROUGHT UP WITH
WITH ANOTHER BILL. EVERYONE
WANTS AND AND LOVE SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS AYE WE BELIEVE I'M A
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER I BELIEVE IN
IN IN TOWNS SCHOOL COUNSELORS. I
BELIEVE IN MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE ALL THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR SCHOOLS
ARE SAFE THE QUESTION COMES DOWN
IS WHO IS GOING TO PAY FOR IT.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE WE ARE
TARGETING ONE GROUP OF LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS WHO SEEK
NOTHING MORE THAT TO EXERCISE
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS IF
WE WERE TO TAX VOTERS IN ORDER
TO FIGHT VOTER FRAUD. IF WE WERE
TO BACK TAX THOSE WHO WERE
DESIRING TO GET MARRIED
ADDITIONALLY IN ORDER TO PAY FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE A THESE ARE
THINGS THAT PEOPLE WOULD
BASICALLY SAY WOULD FIND. A TO
BE APPOINT THE OTHER ISSUE IS
THAT THIS IS A REGRESSIVE TAX IT
IS ALREADY EXPENSIVE TO BE A GUN
OWNER IN THE STATE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. NOW WE'RE GOING
TO DRASTICALLY INCREASE THE COST
OF AN INDIVIDUAL TO BE ABLE TO
TO OWN USE OR BECOME PROFICIENT
IN THE USE OF A FIREARM. IN
PARTICULAR IN THE CASE WHERE
SOMEONE SEEKING TO USE IT TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES YOU'RE GOING
TO MAKE IT COST PROHIBITIVE SO
THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE WHO ARE
LIKELY IN LOW INCOME HIGH CRIME
AREAS. ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE
TO EXERCISE THEIR.
NATIONAL RIGHTS IF THERE'S ONE
THING THAT WE KNOW FROM
JURISPRUDENCE IN THE AREA OF THE
SECOND SECOND AMENDMENT AND ALSO
THE RIGHTS THAT YOU DO NOT HAVE
THE ABILITY TO.
TO.
UNDULY BURDEN INDIVIDUALS WHO
SEEK TO EXERCISE THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS WITHOUT
SOME DIRECT NEXUS NOW UNLESS THE
SCHOOL COUNSELORS ONCE AGAIN ARE
GOING TO BE DIRECTLY ONLY
DEALING WITH INCIDENCES RELATING
TO.
RELATING TO POTENTIAL.
FIREARM USE ON CAMPUS OR THESE
OFFICERS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
PUT ON CAMPUS ARE ONLY GOING TO
DEAL WITH SITUATIONS WHERE THERE
IS AN ACTIVE SHOOTER OR THERE'S
A FIREARM ON CAMPUS. I'M FINDING
IT VERY DIFFICULT TO SEE WHERE
THERE IS A DIRECT NEXUS HERE
THIS BILL IS FRAUGHT WITH
CONSTITUTIONAL PROBLEMS AND THAT
WE BELIEVE FOR THAT REASON.
WE'RE ASKING YOU TO VOTE NO ON
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK HILL AYE GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CATHOLIC REPRESENTING
THE NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION. I REPRESENTING THE
FIREARMS INDUSTRY AMMUNITION
MANUFACTURES WELL SAFARI CLUB
INTERNATIONAL OUTDOOR SPORTS
TEAMS COALITION CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA SPORTSMEN'S LOBBY. IN
OPPOSITION.
TO THE BILL ALL.
WE KIND OF SHARE WE SHARE THE
COMMENTS OF ACTUALLY THE TWO
PRIOR WITNESSES.
CERTAINLY THIS IS WELL
INTENTIONED AND THAT WE ALL ARE
TRYING TO SEEK SOLUTIONS FOR OUR
SCHOOL VIOLENCE BE AND SCHOOL
VIOLENCE EXTENDS BEYOND OF
FIREARMS I THINK THAT GETS LOST
SOMETIMES. AND I THINK THAT THE
SOLUTION NEEDS TO COME FROM THE
GENERAL PUBLIC CAN CERTAINLY.
OUR INDUSTRY STANDS READY TO TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN A
BROADER BASED APPROACH HOWEVER
TAXING THE INDUSTRY IT'S MISTER
DELEUZE'S POINTED OUT.
YOU'RE BASICALLY MAKING.
OUR CITIZENS THAT CHOOSE TO
CARRY FIREARMS TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES FOR HUNTING AND
SHOOTING.
PAY THE BURDEN FOR ALL SCHOOL
SAFETY AND IT SEEMS TO ME IT'S
GOT TO HAVE A GENERAL PUBLIC.
SOLUTION.
WE DO SUPPORT ON NOT ONLY THE
RESOURCE OFFICER'S BUT AS WELL
AS THE COUNSELORS WE THINK IT
AND WE KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR IS
VERY COMMITTED TO.
JUVENILES AND TWO SCHOOL
EDUCATION SO WE SUPPORT WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR BUT NOT THIS
BILL. THE OTHER THING I WOULD
LIKE TO SAY IS THAT. THIS IS
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES YOU NEED
TO TAKE A LOOK AT ALL THE
FIREARMS LAWS THAT YOU HAVE ON
THE BOOKS CURRENTLY. A LOT OF
THE TAXATION AND WE HAD A NON
LEAD AMMUNITION BILL GOING
EFFECT THAT'S GOING TO COST THE
STATE FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS.
AND IT'S ALSO GONNA HAVE
DECREASED REVENUE FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND RESOURCE
ISSUES AND AND YOU HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE STRUGGLING
VERY MUCH WITH THE ARM
PROHIBITED PERSONS PROGRAM WHICH
THEY'VE HAD NUMEROUS DOLLARS
STRONACH. AND IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT YOU NEED TO PRIORITIZE.
WHERE YOU WANT TO FOCUS IN THE
FIREARMS HEARING ON THIS JUST
SEEMS LIKE THE WRONG APPROACH
THANK YOU?
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SAMPRAS
REPRESENTING GUN OWNERS
CALIFORNIA WE GOT A COUPLE OF.
OF A SIGNIFICANT CONCERN SIGN
MAYBE IN A DIFFERENT.
VIEW.
AS MY COLLEAGUES HERE BUT.
THAT THIS BILL SEEMS TO.
AS MUCH AS THE AUTHOR TRIES NOT
TO ASSIGN BLAME ON LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS FOR.
SOMEHOW BEING THE DIRECT RESULT
OF OF GUN VIOLENCE IN SCHOOL.
AND AND THAT CANNOT BE ANY
CLOSER.
IF THEY CANNOT BE TRUTH IT IT'S.
IT'S JUST NOT TRUE.
IT'S JUST NOT TRUE ARE SO TAXING
LAW ABIDING CITIZENS.
BECAUSE OF THE.
THE CRIMES COMMITTED BY A VERY
FEW PEOPLE WE THINK IS IS A
COMPLETELY. THE WRONG WAY TO GO.
ALSO IN IN LISTENING TO THE
AUTHOR'S COMMENTS ON HIS BILL.
IN IN MEDIA REPORTS SAY HE.
.
YOU KNOW HE TALKS ABOUT THE THE
THE THE NEED FOR SCHOOL SAFETY
AND HOW.
ARMING TEACHERS IS THE WRONG
APPROACH.
A VERY RECENT A SURVEY.
NATIONWIDE SURVEY INCLUDED
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS FOUND THAT.
AS MANY AS TWENTY PERCENT OF
TEACHERS.
WOULD BE WILLING TO CARRY OF
FIREARMS.
ON CAMPUS LEGALLY WITH TRAINING.
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND THEIR STUDENTS.
AS A MATTER OF FACT I DON'T OF
THE AUTHORS AWARE THAT THAT WAS
A VERY VIABLE PROGRAM THAT DID
NOT NEED SUPPORT FROM ATTACKS
LIKE THIS. RIGHT HERE IN A IN A
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT HAD
BEEN IN PLACE FOR A LONG TIME.
WHERE UNBEKNOWNST ANYBODY EXCEPT
THE ADMINISTRATOR AND THE PERSON
WHO HAD A PERMIT? AND WAS
TRAINED BY IN COOPERATION WITH
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO BE ABLE
TO RESPOND.
AND IN IT TO AN ACTIVE SHOOTER
SITUATION IMMEDIATELY. THAT WAS
GOING ON IT DIDN'T NEED THIS TAX
AND OF THAT OF COURSE A.
THE RIGHT TO DO THAT WAS
STRIPPED AWAY BY ANOTHER BILL
AND AND NOW HERE WE ARE. TRYING
TO YOU KNOW.
CONSIDER BILL THAT'S GOING TO
RAISE TAXES IN ORDER TO PAY FOR
ON ON CAMPUS.
ARMED GUARDS IN AND.
YOU KNOW.
MORE COUNSELORS WHAT WE'RE GOING
THE WRONG WAY GOING THE WRONG
WAY HERE SO. FOR THIS REASON AND
OTHERS GUN OWNERS CALIFORNIA IS
UNALTERABLY OPPOSED TO THIS TAX.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
THEN READ ON BEHALF NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION'S EUROPEAN
STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU CAN.
YOUR APPROVAL BURGER MAY HAVE A
CALIFORNIA WATER FELL.
IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
DOCTOR BURKE.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THE COUNSELORS
WILL NO LONGER BE ASKED TO BE
REPORTERS THAT'S GOOD.
HOW WOULD THE MONEY BE DIVIDED
BETWEEN RESOURCE OFFICERS AND
COUNSELORS GOES COUNSELORS FIRST
LAW SCHOOLS WHEN THEY HAD CUT
BACKS THE CUT COUNSELORS FIRST
THAT WE'VE BEEN A BIG ISSUE? AND
WILL MAKE SHOES KIDS GET HELP
BECAUSE LOVES KIDS.
TWO I'M TALKING EDUCATORS THEY
COMPLAIN THAT THE KIDS THAT ARE
HAVING PROBLEMS THEY'RE HAVING
DIFFICULTIES AT HOME ARE BEING
BULLIED. SO OBVIOUSLY.
SCHOOL BECAUSE OF THE BEEN CUT A
LOT OF SCHOOLS HAVE.
SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICERS ALREADY
MUSTER LARGE DISTRICTS.
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICTS DRUG
CALIFORNIA ARE EMPLOYED SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICERS
IT'S THE MONEY WOULD FIRST GO
TOWARDS COUNSELORS. OUT IT
INDICATES A PLANET THEN
OBVIOUSLY THEY CAN ADD
ADDITIONAL COUNSELORS OF STE
HAVE COUNCILS ALREADY YOU CAN
ADDITIONAL COUNTS REGIONAL
SCHOOLS.
AS FAR AS REACHED SCHOOL
RESOURCE AUTHORS YOU CANNOT ADD
ADDITIONAL SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICERS.
SO THIS IS THEY DON'T HAVE THEM.
IE SOME SMALL DISTRICTS WOULD BE
ABLE WHO EMPLOY SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICERS AND ONE SINGLE SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICERS. BEEN AROUND
FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS PUBLIC
LONGER THAN THAT NOW.
OKAY THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A QUORUM SO.
WHILE WE HAVE IT LET'S TAKE
ADVANTAGE.
MS HYLAND WILL CALL THE ROLL.
BURKE.
HERE.
WHO GROWTH HERE BONTA CHIU?
GRAY HERE.
MCCARTY MELENDEZ MULLIN.
QUIRK.
VOEPEL YOU.
WE HAVE A QUORUM ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING HEARING NONE WHICH I'D
CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM MADAM
CHAIR. IS NOT TOO OFTEN YOU GET
THE ACLU IN THE GUN RIGHTS FOLKS
THE SAME SIDE.
BUT WERE NOT TRYING TO BREAK
THE BANK HERE. AND I'LL TELL YOU
WHAT COME WE DO TALK TO BE DO
TAX LAW ABIDING CITIZENS TIRE
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TO KEEP
US SAFE. THAT GOES ON RIGHT NOW.
THE SCHOOL SHE HAS BEEN GOING
ON FOR DECADES NOW WE TRIED A
LOT OF THINGS I DON'T BELIEVE.
GUN PER PROHIBITIONS IS THE
ANSWER TO THIS SO WE'RE TRYING
SOMETHING DIFFERENT TO ACTUALLY
SAVE OUR KIDS.
AFTER ALL SPEAKERS HERE KNOWN
AND WORKED IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
SPENT THIRTY YEARS IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT I WAS THE CAPTAIN I
COMMITTED SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICERS.
I TAUGHT IN THE SCHOOLS
PREVENTION PROGRAMS LIKE THIS.
WE TOOK GUNS OFF KIDS THAT ARE
BRINGING GUNS ON CAMPUS TO DO
VIOLENCE
SO I THINK MY EXPERTISE IN
DEALING WITH THESE PROBLEMS FAR
OUTWEIGHS OUR PANEL SPEAKERS.
WHO HAVE EXPRESSED THEIR
OPINIONS WHICH ARE JUST THAT?
?
THIS IS SOMETHING NEW AND
SOMETHING DIFFERENT. AND IN
TALKING TO TEACHERS IT IS EASY
TO PICK UP THOSE KIDS ARE TO BE
PROBLEMATIC AND TO REALLY HELP
THEM. EXISTING IN ONE OF MY
SCHOOLS DISTRICTS DOWN AND
ENGULFED. FOR ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS
THEY HAVE A SCHOOL COUNSELOR.
AND A LICENSED SOCIAL WORKER ON
CAMPUS BIG WHAT DO HOME VISITS
TO THE PROBLEM CHILDREN THAT
REALLY MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE
BUT MOST SCHOOLS CAN AFFORD
THAT.
SO THE SOMETHING OUT OF THE BOX
AT THE ORDINARY TO DEFY THOSE
KIDS THERE TROUBLE. AND TO HELP
THEM.
NOT TO PUT IMAGE EL NOT TO REST
AND TO HELP THEM.
AND HELP IN WHATEVER WAY WE CAN
BE THEIR HOME WHERE MAYBE TO
MENTAL HEALTH AND CHANGE THE
DYNAMIC ON THIS WITH THESE KIDS
ARE SCHOOL SHOOTERS BECAUSE LIKE
I SAID EARLIER THE STATISTICS.
PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT IT ALREADY SO
WE TRY TO CHANGE THIS AND I'M A
GUN OWNER I HAVE A LOT OF GUNS
AT HOME I BELIEVE IN GUN RIGHTS.
IS THE TAX
AND WE'RE GONNA FIGURE OUT WHAT
IS GOING TO BE BUT ANYTHING THAT
CAN HELP PREVENT A SCHOOL
SHOOTING HELP A CHILD. THE MONEY
WE SAVE IN THE TREASURY SAVE.
TO ME THAT IF THERE'S NO
COMPARISON SO I SAVED A LOT OF
THINGS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
ASSEMBLY TAKING WAY FIREARMS IS
A RIGHT ANSWER. ON THIS POPE
GETS US THERE CENTER STAFF WE
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
NOT.
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOPER THIS GIVES OF
THOSE WHO BUY FIREARMS AND
AMMUNITION OPPORTUNITY TO BE
PART OF THE SOLUTION NOT JUST
PART OF THE ISSUE AND I. I I
WOULD THINK THAT THEY WOULD
EMBRACE THAT OPPORTUNITY
WITHOUT.
THE CHAIR'S RECOMMENDATION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO PUBLIC SAFETY
MISS HIGHLANDER WILL CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS A
MINUTE TO PUBLIC SAFETY PER.
BURKE AYE BROUGH. RONELL BONTA
CHIU. CHU AYE GRAY.
GRAY NELL MCCARTY. MELENDEZ
MULLIN.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL IT'S THREE THREE IT'S ON
COLLEGE THREE TO THREE THAT'S ON
CALLING EVEN THREE.
RETURNING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB TWENTY THREE OH THREE.
I NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WAS HIGHLY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
BURKE AYE BURKE AYE GROWTH.
RONELL BONTA CHIU. CHU HI GRAY.
GRAY NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
MELINDA'S
MULLIN QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
VOEPEL.
FELLOW IT'S THREE TO.
THREE MORE.
THE BILL IS THREE TO TWO YOU
NEED THREE MORE. MOVING TO FILE
ITEMS SIXTY AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
AND IN A MOTION AND A SECOND.
AND THIS IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND MS HIGHLY
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE
BURKE AYE WORLD. RONELL BONTA.
CHU. CHU AYE GRAY.
GRAY NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
MELINDA'S.
MULLIN.
QUIRK.
QUIRK NOT VOTING VOEPEL.
THE FELLOW THAT VOTE IS TO TWO
O'CLOCK COFFEE.
THAT'S TO TO ITS ON CALL.
AND MISTER COOPER'S HERE.
BOTH.
S. MISTER FRASIER'S HERE EXCUSE
ME.
COLONEL Y..
THIS.
I
THIS IS.
SO WHICH ONE.
ITEM NUMBER.
ITEM NUMBER THREE GRAY NOT
VOTING TO AYE.
PLEASE PLEASE.
THEY NEED TO LEARN ANALYTICS ONE
UNTIL THE CALL BACK ON WAS A
TWENTY THREE A THREE.
BUT DON'T CALL AB TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY.
ITEM NUMBER SIX.
GREY NOT VOTING TO TO KNOW.
AND THAT ITEMS SONG CALL
WITHOUT. THAT I TO HEAR.
THANK YOU MOVING TO FIVE I DON'T
WANT AB SEVENTEEN FORTY ONE.
MISTER BONTA WOULD YOU LIKE TO
OPEN I WOULD THINK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES AND.
STAFF I WANT TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
PROPOSED TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS ON
PAGE FOR THE ANALYSIS THANK YOU
FOR THOSE.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY ONE SIMPLY
REMOVES THE TEN PERCENT PENALTY
ON NON. ELECTRONIC FUND TRANSFER
PAYMENTS OVER TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
FOR CULTIVATION AN EXCISE TAXES
ON BOTH MEDICAL AND DON'T USE
CANNABIS AND FOR SALES AND USE
TAXES. ON ADULT USE CANNABIS IT
BUILDS ON A BILL THAT WE PASSED
AND HERE IN THIS LET IN THIS
LEGISLATURE BEFORE AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN WE PASSED AB EIGHT
TWENTY ONE BY MISTER GIPSON.
HOW OF THAT MEASURE ONLY APPLY
THE SALES AND USE TAXES ON
MEDICAL CANNABIS SO? THIS BILL
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY ONE WILL WILL
APPLY TO THE WHOLE GAMUT OF
CANNABIS TAXES.
CULTIVATION EXCISE MEDICAL AND
ADULT USE.
AND AND SALES AND USE TAX ON
ADULT USE CANNABIS.
I WE ARE NO FEDERAL LAW
CURRENTLY CLASSIFIES CANNABIS AS
A SCHEDULE ONE DRUG WHICH MAKES.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR THOSE
IN THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY TO BANK
OR USE FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS.
AND SO MOST CANNABIS BUSINESSES
HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO OPERATE
AND PAY TAXES AND CASH IS THAT'S
THE ONLY WAY THAT THEY CAN PAY
THEIR TAXES.
I WOULD THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE
TO PENALIZE THEM FOR DOING SO WE
WOULD YOU WANT IN THE PAY THEIR
TAXES AND BY REMOVING THIS
PENALTY I THINK WOULD ENCOURAGE
COMPLIANCE AND I'M MORE TAX
REVENUE FOR THE STATE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU FOR THE CONSIDERATION.
AND NOT.
I HAVE WITH ME HE.
CASEY O'CONNOR A REPRESENTATIVE
FROM THE OFFICE OF.
BOARD BECAUSE THEY CAN MEMBER
FIONA MA AND AMY JENKINS.
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER AND THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME'S CASEY O'CONNOR AND THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR BOARD
OF EQUALIZATION VICE CHAIR FIONA
MA. WE WERE THE CO SPONSOR OF
THE BILL LAST YEAR IN OUR HELP
WITH A CO SPONSOR AGAIN THIS
YEAR WE BELIEVE AND. OTHER VICE
CHAIRS ALWAYS FOCUSED ON
ENCOURAGING IMPORTING VOLUNTARY
COMPLIANCE AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
ONE DOES THIS BY FURTHER
INCENTIVIZING THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY. TO LEGALLY COMPILED
CALIFORNIA'S TAX CODE IT'S
UNFAIR FOR US TO TAX AN INDUSTRY
AND THEN PANEL OF APPLY OF
PENALTY WAIVER ON TOP OF THAT.
YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T HAVE PINK
ACCOUNT SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE APPRECIATE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU HAD TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AMY JENKINS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AS
WELL AS A NUMBER OF.
INDEPENDENT CANNABIS OPERATORS
OF FOR THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED OUR WE ARE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THE SPELL UP CANNABIS
BUSINESS SHOULD NOT BE PENALIZED
FOR TRYING TO COMPLY WITH THE
TOP
CODE. BY MAKING PAYMENTS AND
CASH ESPECIALLY WHEN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS MADE IT ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO BANK THE
INDUSTRY'S PREVIOUSLY STATED. OF
DISCOURAGING CASH PAYMENTS ONLY
INCREASES NONCOMPLIANCE IN AN
INDUSTRY THAT WANTS TO COMPLY
WITH ITS TAX OBLIGATIONS. FOR
THESE REASONS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE SPELLING ENCOURAGE
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MEMBERS JASON BRYANT OF AFTER
CALIFORNIA GROWERS ASSOCIATION
APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS SAID
LEADERSHIP ON THE ON THE BILL
AND AND WE ARE SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ARONOW IT ON
BEHALF OF THE CANNABIS IS SHOULD
BE XIN ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE WERE OF
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
KENNY.
SEEING NONE ELECTRICAL.
LIKE BECAUSE I THINK YOU MEMBERS
WERE NOT AWARE OF ANY OPPOSITION
WE THINK IT'S A COMMON SENSE
BILL RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
RECOMMENDATIONS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THAILAND CALL THE ROLL. BURKE
AYE BURKE AYE BROUGH BONTA AYE
BONTA AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY MELENDEZ.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK.
VOEPEL.
IT'S NOT QUITE.
WE NEED ONE MORE VOTE.
IS FILE ITEM ONE A. B. SEVENTEEN
FORTY ONE.
AND WILL LEAVE THAT ON CALL FOR
ONE MARKET. THE COMMAND CHAIR
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES THINK IS
THAT. I THINK YOU MOVING TO FILE
ITEM.
TO AB TWENTY NINETY SIX MISTER
FRASER WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SIX.
WHO'S HERE TODAY AND I LET WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING ALL
THE COMMITTEES RECOMMEND.
RICK RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS.
MY GOAL WAS TO CLOSE THE GAP OF
THOSE WAITING FOR LIFE SAVING
ORGANS AND THOSE WHO ARE ABLE TO
RECEIVE THEM.
AB TWENTY NINETY SIX WOULD HELP
ACHIEVE THIS GOAL BY AUTHORIZING
THE ADDITION OF THE DONATE LIFE
CALIFORNIA VOLUNTARY TAX CUT
CONTRIBUTION FUND.
AS A VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION
CONTRIBUTION FUND ON THE
PERSONAL INCOME TAX RETURN.
FOR OVER A DECADE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS PRIORITIZE
IMPORTANCE OF INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF REGISTERED ORGAN AYE
AYE. AND TISSUE DOORS IN THE
STATE.
AB TWENTY NINETY SIX WE WILL
REINFORCE THE STATE'S COMMITMENT
BY GIVING CAO GETTING
CALIFORNIANS.
THE OPPORTUNITY EACH YEAR TO
SUPPORT THE REGISTRY.
THE REGISTRY IS VITAL WHO IS
VITALLY IMPORTANT AS OVER ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND AND
INDIVIDUALS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
ARE WAITING FOR LIFESAVING
TRANSPLANTS
AND TWENTY ONE INDIVIDUALS DIE
EACH DAY.
WITHOUT A TRANSPLANT.
FOR THIS REASON IT IS CRUCIAL TO
EXPAND THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO BE ABLE TO
FINANCIALLY SUPPORT DONATE LIFE
CALIFORNIA. AND GROWING THE
REGISTRY OF ORGAN. AYE AND
TISSUE DONORS AND THE GIFT OF
LIFE.
A VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION FUND
WILL ALLOW CALIFORNIA'S TO MAKE
THIS CHOICE EACH YEAR.
NOT JUST EVERY FIVE.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO DONATE
LIFE CALIFORNIA ALLOW THE
ORGANIZATION TO EXPAND ITS ACT
EDUCATIONAL AND OUTREACH
OPPORTUNITIES AND WORK TO
ACHIEVE THE ORGANIZATIONS
ORGANIZATIONS VISION ONE DAY.
ALL CALIFORNIA'S WILL EMBRACE
ORGAN.
I TISSUE DONATIONS AS OUR
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY.
WITH ME TODAY HAVE LEADERSHIP
FROM BERNIE LIFE CALIFORNIA TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND JIM MARTIN MC CEO
DONATE LIFE CALIFORNIA SPONSOR
AB TWENTY NINETY SIX TONY LIFE
CALIFORNIA'S THE STATE
AUTHORIZED NONPROFIT ORGANIZING
TISSUE DONOR REGISTRY.
WITH OVER FOURTEEN HALF MILLION.
CALIFORNIANS CURRENTLY
REGISTERED AS DONORS.
OUR CALIFORNIA REGISTRATION RATE
IS ABOUT FORTY SIX PERCENT
TRAILINGTHE NATIONAL AVERAGE OF
FIFTY FOUR PERCENT.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX
CALIFORNIANS HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SIGN UP FOR THE
ORGAN NINE TISSUE DONOR REGISTRY
ON DIEM THE DRIVER'S LICENSE.
AND ID APPLICATION RENEWAL FORM
ALONG WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DONATE TWO DOLLARS TO OUR
ORGANIZATION.
THE DOLLARS COLLECTED AS A
RESULT OF THESE CONTRIBUTIONS
ARE A PRIMARY SOURCE OF FUNDING
AND COVER OPERATING COSTS OF
MANAGING THE REGISTRY COMMUNITY
OUTREACH.
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA DMV RUNS ON A
FIVE YEAR LICENSE RENEWAL CYCLE.
OUR FUNDING IS INCONSISTENT WITH
SOME YEARS BEING HIGHER OR LOWER
THAN OTHERS DEPENDING ON THE
NUMBER OF DRIVERS LICENSE
RENEWALS.
AB TWENTY NINETY SIX WERE
ALLOWED TO NAY LIFE CALIFORNIA
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ANOTHER
FUNDING OPPORTUNITY. FURTHER
SUPPORT THE MONARCHY
MODERNIZATION OF THE REGISTRY
AND OUR EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
ACTIVITIES AS WE. SEEK TO
ENCOURAGE MORE CALIFORNIANS TO%
DONATE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THINKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
AM ON DON'T LIKE CALIFORNIA'S
BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
MORE IMPORTANTLY I'M A DONOR
MOM MY SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD SON
WAS AN ORGANIZED TISSUE DONOR IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN FOLLOWING A
CAR ACCIDENT.
AND.
SUBSEQUENTLY I'VE CHANGED MY
CAREER SO THAT I COULD BE
INVOLVED IN MAKING SURE THAT
MORE PEOPLE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO JOIN I DON'T LIVE CALIFORNIA
REGISTRY AND. AS BEING A PART OF
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS THERE'S
NEVER ENOUGH INFORMATION TO GET
IN FRONT OF ALL OF THE HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS IN FRONT OF ALL
OF THE COMMITTEE. THE COMMUNITY
GROUPS THAT NEED TO HEAR OUR
MESSAGE THAT THEY UNDERSTAND.
THAT THEIR COMMUNITIES ARE
WAITING FOR LIFESAVING
TRANSPLANT AND WITHOUT PEOPLE
JOINING THE DONATE LIFE
CALIFORNIA REGISTRY.
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TRANSPLANT
SOME PEOPLE DIE I ASK YOUR VOTE
AYE ON THIS BILL.
I THINK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
GIVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR IS A. A PROUD MEMBER OF
THE COMMITTEE HAS A PINK TAUGHT
ON HIS DRIVER'S LICENSE.
I REALLY WOULD APPRECIATE A AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AYE VOTE
FOR THE SCHOOL OR THE
FOUNDATION.
YOU AGREE TO THE AMENDMENTS THE
AMENDMENTS ARE AS FOLLOWS ONE
ORGAN AND TISSUE DONOR REGISTRY
VOLUNTARY TAX CONTRIBUTION FUNDS
TO PROVIDE THAT THE FINE SHALL
BE ADDED AS SOON AS SPACES
AVAILABLE THREE ADDED A STANDARD
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND ARE
MINIMUM CONTRIBUTION
REQUIREMENTS. FOR ADDED AT
SUNSET DEEPER ARE IN T.
C.-SECTION EIGHT ONE EIGHT EIGHT
SEVEN THREE.
FIVE ADOPTED TECHNO THEN IT'S
NOTED IN COMMENT  OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
DEFILING CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE. BURKE
AYE ROLE BONTA.
BONTA AYE CHU CHU ARE AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY MELENDEZ.
ONE IS I MULLIN. MULLIN AYE
QUIRK VOEPEL.
THOUGH I.
BUILT.
THAT GOES OUT.
THEN WE CAN GO NOW.
IF THE
SIGN ANYTHING IN BLUE I WILL
LIFT THE CALL ON FILE ITEM ONE
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY ONE.
CALL THE ABSENTEES.
GROW.
MCCARTY MELINDA'S
MELINDA SNOW.
QUIRK.
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NO.
PLEASE REPLACE A COUPLE.
FOR PLATE REPLACE A COLUMN FILE
ITEM ONE.
WE FILE ITEM THREE AB TWENTY
THREE OH THREE LEFT THE CALL
CALL THE ABSENTEES.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE MCCARTY.
MELINDA'S.
NO WONDER SMELL MULLIN.
MULLIN ON.
S. THAT FILLS OUT THAT BILL IS
OUT MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIVE AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY SEVEN.
WELL IF THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENTEES.
BONTA.
BONTA AYE GRAY BOOKS USING
MCCARTY.
MELINDA'S LINDA SNOW.
MULLIN.
MULLIN I.
REPLACE THE COLONY. OR NO PLACE
REPLACE A COLUMN FILE ITEM. FIVE
MOVIE FILE ITEM SIX AB TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY.
LIFT THE CALLING COOLEY
ABSENTEES BONTA.
BONTA AYE.
MCCARTY.
MELINDA'S MELINDA SNOW MULLIN.
MULLIN ONLY.
THE ONLY CURRY PLACE. WE'RE
GONNA PLACE TO CALL BACK ON FILE
ITEM SIX
FORTY ONE CALL THE APPS.
PEROT MCCARTY.
ITEM NUMBER ONE.
MCCARTY I.
STEP BILLS OUT.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
MOVING A FILE ITEM.
MCCARTY WHICH LIKE TO ADAM'S
ITEM NUMBER TWO.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ARE YOU IT
WITH WHICH SURE IS THAT A AYE.
OKAY.
THAT WELL FILMING FILE ITEM
THREE AB TWENTY THREE OH THREE
LIFTING THE CALL.
AND THAT'S HOW THEY HAVE SET
REALISTIC MCCARTY.
BUT BUILT OUT.
LIVING A FILE ITEM FIVE AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY SEVEN LEFT IN
THE CALL.
MCCARTY.
CARTIER LA.
THAT BILL IS OUT MOVING TO FILE
ITEM SIX AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTEEN.
OF
ITEM NUMBER SIX
.
WE ARE TURNED